i just got to say too uh
they take pickpocketing to a whole new
level they are like magicians in this
room they are there are scenes where
you're like you couldn't have hidden a
swipe in there there's literally like
feet apart and there's no arms distance
that could have accounted for that
they'll be standing like this far apart
some character on the walk away
and then it is magical oh my god they
stole my points
what's happening reject nation greg and
john chartered their way to the movie
theaters over at cinemark to watch the
movie uncharted the way to see this
movie would be in the theaters with its
massive action scenes especially in the
last half of this film cinemark thank
you for inviting us and also you guys
can have a private watch party for this
movie when we were coming prior it was
20 people now you can bring up to 30
people and watching with our buddies
this way being able to talk amongst
ourselves laugh me telling them to shut
up stop chewing your food so loud was
perfect i am the perfect person to go
have a private watch party with as i am
abusive to all my family and friends but
you know what it makes for a better
viewing experience in the end now let's
talk about our feelings for uncharted
all right guys so let's get this out of
the way i played the first three
uncharted games i don't remember them at
all i remember like tiny bits and pieces
so when it comes to oh my god did they
ruin my beloved video game i don't know
maybe it seems likely to be totally
honest games probably felt a little bit
more like an authentic movie too long
story short with this film tom holland
plays nathan drake a young version a
little boy in an old man's body or
something is going on here it's benjamin
button
and he teams up with mark wahlberg's
sully to go to traverse the world
looking for treasure and it's one of
those you know swashbuckling
tomb raider mummy indiana jones spy
wannabe types of films you know what
i'll say like after the first trailer we
were pretty honest about our feelings i
was like that didn't look too great but
here's the honest-to-god truth the movie
was better than i expected it to be but
also
way more boring than i expected it to be
at the same time yeah it's like it's
charmingly bad and endearingly boring so
let's talk about some positives first
tom holland was not bad he's very
affable he's enjoyable to watch oh crap
oh crap there's a lot of those adr lines
that are like what does nathan drake say
when he's in the middle of a fight oh
crap oh [ __ ] he was really fun uh he's
tom holland plus parkour and bartending
skills like in all sincerity it took me
a while to really buy him in the role
not because i was like is this accurate
to the way i remember the video game
it's a very specific type of like manly
role well it requires like a harrison
ford type almost it requires somebody
with that rugged edge who's still
charming and fun christopher pratt like
chris pratt yeah exactly let's get owen
from jurassic park in here yeah tom
holland has this very clean every man
very good-natured type of charm so it
does feel like the movie is very much
trying to get him to a point where
you're like no this dude's edgy i did
like him in the action this is really
doing a lot of his own stunts and it is
great it's like i think we always heard
that with spider-man to actually be like
that's really tom holland moving around
like that that's actually really
impressive mark wahlberg look i he is
not anything like sully from the video
game you know what he is like is mark
wahlberg he's like mark wahlberg and he
does a good job at that mark wahlberg
impression he's very very good as that
and daddy a brother for me i
and i think him and uh tom holland you
know their chemistry kind of flip-flops
from time to time it's just kind of odd
in the first half of this movie i would
say i think in the last half is when it
started to really mesh together a lot
more in the first half i was just kind
of like i should be having fun but this
movie feels a little soulless last flat
that's probably a more accurate word
than soulless it was felt like it was
striving for spirit it just
felt like hollywood screenplay you know
really
and then somebody finally picked it up
and went
hey can we can we graph some uncharted
motifs onto this and get some
celebrities here we go we've got a
property let's do it a lot of the the
pacing and a lot of the the jokes and
just the energy about it like you said
just feels a little bit flat and
unexciting despite how much globe
trotting and exposition of just
being like a historical detail my god
just so much of it i just gotta say too
uh
they take pickpocketing to a whole new
level they are like magicians in this
room they are there are scenes where
you're like you couldn't have hidden a
swipe in there there's literally like
feet apart and there's no arms distance
that could have accounted for that
they'll be standing like this far apart
some character on the walk away
yeah there are a lot of very strange
logical decisions about physics and uh
people's ability to pickpocket the
efficacy of electronics in varying
difficult uh weather situations antonio
manderis is wasted and goofy here's the
thing though the last half has has some
of the most uncharted vibe that i think
you would want in terms of just the
actual movie and in terms of the action
scenes like the action scenes there's
two big set pieces in this film that get
just bonkers they're they're ridiculous
everyone in our theater was just
laughing i wasn't i was happy
genuinely i was like i don't care how
freaking stupid this is this is so fun
it got really fun in those moments and
this movie has two post credits scenes
count it two they really want that
sequel those post credits scenes felt a
little bit more like chart of the game
than most of the movies it's like mortal
kombat in that sense where you're like
oh maybe the sequel will be uncharted
the whole movie spends its time building
up to these things where you're like oh
we're finally gonna get to something
that really resembles uncharted at it
and it almost kinda does i'm just like
the movie's fine it's just uh it falls a
little flat full of cliches it's really
nothing special it doesn't really help
with like can video games be good
adaptations go watch tomb raider with
alicia vikander i prefer that one i mean
that at least actually kind of resembles
what the game is is kind of supposed to
be like you see like i barely even
remember the uncharted game and i'm just
watching this movie on its own and just
on its own it's like
it's fine that's like the whole vibe i
have like that's fine if this was on tv
i'd be like it's a little boring but
it's a little entertaining too as much
as there is to gripe about it i was
always kind of smiling and chuckling for
one reason or another uh so yeah it's
it's weird it's like i can't really say
it's a good movie you need to go see it
but if you want to have fun you you
actually you might in spite of
everything that's actually happening on
screen i would say that there's a couple
of action scenes in here that are worth
watching the theaters alone i mean that
sincerely but yeah overall with the
ratings i'd give it like uh you know of
uh
i don't care um
yeah just you know make up your own god
if you're gonna watch it watch it all
right i find it fairly ironic that a
video game that borrowed so much from
movies and was lauded for being
especially cinematic made for a movie
that doesn't feel like it bothered to be
very like cinematic or borrow from the
movies that the game was actually
borrowing from itself we're gonna have
these two people have been watching us
this whole time awkwardly just trying to
figure out how to formulate their
opinions no just get them on here to
switch the mics greg mentioned this film
fell a little bit flat on the jokes i
thought this film was unintentionally
funny in many moments like there were
some serious moments where we were balls
out laughing so i mean there were some
moments i really enjoyed but overall
falls out
laughing yes i don't think i've ever
heard
yes we were balls out laughing
yes yes exactly
yes we were come to cinemark you'll see
that's where ball's out laughing happens
at cinemark yeah this film
can sometimes uh be very mildly
entertaining but in a very
unintentionally funny way aaron what did
you think had all the testicular
fortitude of a 40 year old man edging to
find his uh freedom and passion again i
like tom holland i like mark wahlberg
but i feel like oh man this is like the
definition of obligatory i played all
the uncharted games so uh i am something
of a semi expert and yeah it was it was
not good
how did you really feel uh it's uh it's
not horrible it's perfectly acceptable
tnt cable fall asleep kind of movie this
movie is it exists you know and if
you're going to fall asleep somewhere do
it a cinemark they got the best seats
there you have it folks there you have
it come here go to the market
and take a nap take a nap
very comfortable
seating conditioning they'll turn the
volume up real loud
they have officially revoked our passes
to go watch the batman